Roza Farabaugh is an artist who's
currently living and working in berlin
she has been seen quite widely in Europe
she's been in two Venice Biennale her
work has been in major museums however
she's had very little exposure in the
United States so I knew that she was one
of the first people I wanted to present
here so in this exhibition here at this
Center I'm showing for the first time in
the United States a larger overview of
my work so film installation but
sculptural works as well plus a new
piece the color out of space that is now
showing you for the first time as a
sculptural work Rosa initially studied
film as well as fine arts and that's
something that's very clear in this
exhibition and throughout her work which
really uses
and celluloid film as theme and material
what you see in the gallery are a number
of projector sculptures that make the
mechanism of projection very obvious I'm
very interested in working with a film
in a sculptural way so and creating
objects out of off the film and also
working very spatially and site-specific
with the material and and images we
early on decided that we would structure
the exhibition around ideas of time and
landscape roses very interested in sort
of deep time geological time time spans
that are sort of not grasped the ball by
the human mind and the way in which that
becomes evident in landscapes in general
I'm interested in traces that society
leaves around us so I'm trying to to
make a sense of those traces and how we
perceive them and how time plays a role
in that and it's it's a kind of
archeological approach to toot-toot I'm
Rosa engages with some of the same
topics or questions as many of the
scientists at MIT do for example the new
piece and the show called the color out
of space uses images of planets and
stars gathered at an observatory and she
has created a soundtrack in which
astronomers and writers and artists sort
of reflect on the universe both
scientifically and poetically and you
kind of come to understand that in some
ways the ways of thinking about this
material are not so different and then
you know some of the works are simply
quite beautiful
you